wow
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
we are live it is the leftovers
yeah
we're back baby Donald Trump is back
which means our ratings are going to be
going through the roof here the closer
we get to the presidential boy that's
right I love it trumpets ladies and
gentlemen we are all domestic terrorists
that's true actually
um welcome everybody to leftovers it is
November 17th a beautiful Thursday
Hassan [ __ ] how are you my friend I'm
feeling pretty good I'm a little groggy
so are you uh why you don't put groggy
on me you are a little groggy I didn't
have like this sexy you got like sexy
sick voice do you ever feel like your
voice I don't have a sexy I don't have a
sick Voice period it's a little sexy but
you can't come into my house when you
talk nasally it sounds hotter I think
it's like hey what's up guys
I can't I can't wear this hat and try to
be sexy by the way I'm rocking dude you
are such a [ __ ] look at this himbo shirt
I didn't realize how revealing it is
yeah what do you mean you're [ __ ] out
of my shirt bro I never put on so much
cleavage before yeah let it ride dude
this is it it's it's we are all in our
[ __ ] era
you're in your [ __ ] era you have so much
chest it's like so many brother Ethan
the haircut that you have currently and
I told you this even before you got it
the haircut that you have is the
[ __ ] haircut a man can like it's
like a it's like a [ __ ] boy billboard
yeah it is true okay you are you're
basically wearing a pearl necklace and
and you know those those circular uh
Spectacles on top of that currently this
is a hell of a look though I don't know
if I'll be able to rock this for the
whole episode I should be real why not
show the [ __ ] guns dude it's the
goddamn gun show Timbo Jim
you look skinny thanks bro hey I'm
kidding oh thank you guys now you know
I've been working hard trying to lose
the [ __ ] weight
I'd like to live past the age of 50
ideally maybe I've been sick that'd be
nice if I'm feeling a little bit greedy
yeah and um anyway himbo Jim merch
that's his song see that looks like
normal on you
it's pretty it's kind of [ __ ] on me
too
now did you make the conscious decision
to go this deep or did it come deeper
than you expected no I think it's it's a
basic it's like a it's like a basic tank
top I think you might have gone like one
one size too high maybe what are you
wearing what size you wearing right now
I don't know
I believe that is a 1x oh is it XL yeah
yeah I wear a double XL so and and do
you shave your chest you don't have any
hair there on your chest your mind no I
do yeah you do okay I'm I'm hairy I
think like I had shaved I had shaved
before not this shoot but like
you know it takes a while to grow back
so
um I don't know I think it was like in
it was like a little hairy but not too
hairy I see and does it get itchy when
you shave your chest is it yes is it
worth it yes it's not like I mean it is
itchy for like a week too yeah like I
don't have that issue anywhere else I
manscape all around right but I don't
have that issue anywhere else just my
chest when I when I shave my chest even
a little bit like trim it yeah it's
crazy it gets so itchy for like a week
and and when you say you don't have that
problem elsewhere but do you shave your
genitals down to the skin yeah
down to the skin yeah you're [ __ ]
hairless around your dick I leave a
little bit of a happy trail but that's
it oh my god dude you you shave it all
the way down yeah how do you get like
the stem and [ __ ] without I'm always
afraid there's a body I use a body
shaver
like I've been using like Philips and
River Alcove that's like rounded and
even balls you just like you can really
rub no that's like a face shaver right
there so what the [ __ ] is a what is it
it's like a body shape is it Philip
Phillips Norelco body that I've been
using for years and years like I just
replace it when it gets dull kind of but
I gotta look up what's a body shaver
because I never found something
that I'm comfortable putting like on the
skin because every time I do it I just
be I'll just be real with you guys
disaster is striking every time you Nick
your dick I mean everyone's skin is
different right like everyone's body's
over here that's that's what I use yeah
like one of the versions of that yeah
[ __ ] bro
so do you use that on your face and your
balls too no okay so you have different
no of course I have different ones it
doesn't bother me I use it I'll just be
honest I do I take a shower afterwards
yeah I'm the same way I take a shower
your face shaver on your balls that is
insane well it is what it is bro I'm not
a [ __ ] listen bro I'm not a like
hedonist I don't over consume [ __ ] I
don't need two Ray I'm a people I'm a
man of the people okay you are you are
literally the most serious as [ __ ] you
are the most loyal Soldier for frozen
pizzas how are you gonna act like you're
yeah proletariat bro exactly I'm a man
of the people we already established
Pizza is already like a cheap uh thing
to consume it's affordable regardless
Pizza is expensive actually that's very
illusion yeah that's Brandon's America
baby
the price of dough has gone way up yeah
there's no turkeys anymore you can't
even get a turkey for Thanksgiving there
you go we learned you like turkey not
really thank you okay good we agree you
know what I mean like let's just be real
turkey it's the there's a reason we only
eat it once a year it's because it
[ __ ] sucks I love chicken I eat it
every day turkey's kind of mid I'll just
say it I'll come out and say it turkey
kind of a mid uh I I agree I agree
um I'll eat a duck if it's done well
duck is better than everything's better
than turkey it it's the worst meat it
really isn't that good you know I'll
take any meat a resident vegan
but vegetarian just to recap we learned
that a Hassan shaves his dick all the
way down so yeah and my butthole too you
shave your butthole with that yeah oh
well I don't go butthole to face I go I
go uh I go inside of the cheeks it's so
smooth like when you're serious yeah
well how do you make sure you get
everything is shaved evenly down there I
just couldn't tell I'm a professional
you don't you don't have like a mirror
on the ground or something crazy no I
don't need to you can you know give it a
field test you know wow wow
um but yeah no I oh God the first the
first wipe after that is so smooth it's
like
perfect yeah I mean I understand you're
propulsion because again I don't go from
ass to face it's just pubes to face yeah
my ass to face is a whole different
ballgame well that would not I wouldn't
do that what what's the difference
though if you're the [ __ ] out of your
ass
if you're clean though if you're clean I
don't [ __ ] care how clean you are bro
oh no it's close it's a closed up space
I I shave my armpits too
oh really man I trim them as well it's I
think it's a Turkish thing like I say I
don't know maybe Middle Eastern I do
exactly the same thing everything you're
saying I do the same yeah you go dig you
go skin down on the Dick yeah you have
no hair around your your dick nope whoa
yeah I don't know why this so I'm I'm a
hairy boy I don't wanna I don't wanna
I don't even like being hairy like I I
don't like being hairy at all at this
point though it's like one it's
convenience like I don't want to shave
all the time and two like
the ladies like it you know they like no
hair around the dick at all
no I'm just saying like they don't they
they like that I'm hairy yeah oh they
like that you're hairy hi I'm dick Tiff
uh they like they like that I'm Hair Pro
tip but I but I shave that area
regardless well there it is guys uh now
you know
the boys are shaving down there all the
way I think it's also like I said I
think it's also a consequence of uh you
know just
being Middle Eastern and associating
hair with like not being clean I guess I
don't know can we do awaken the people
yes thank you Trump he's back by the way
can we do a poll real fast just for
Science and I think this is important
okay ladies um
we need to pull do you want any hair how
could I how do I phrase this no hair
around the dick
S I leave a happy trail up top
bro there's no hair around the deck I'll
leave a happy trail up top I don't know
why that confuses you so much though I
just want to know what's the preference
out here I'm trying to learn okay so
this is a question for uh let's say
those attracted to uh um yeah
well no no I want to know from the
ladies suck a little bit right that's
what I mean okay so and the Fellas too
what do you mean that's what I'm saying
no I I listen Okay so we're not
interested I'm I'm CIS okay
you're assistant breeders
this information is foreign
um when I'm gonna hit I'm gonna vote n a
okay so because I'm gonna be honest I
voted you can vote I mean I'm cheating
you're like [ __ ] up the thing though
yeah I voted for sure I won't tell you
how I voted but I know how you bought it
you got no damn you got weights and fish
brother oh wow this is a very
um balanced poll here yeah this is
interesting actually crazy uh they're
saying bad pull Dan oh really
I could see our audience liking here bro
what the [ __ ] you wrote this like a
[ __ ] ballot provision ladies do you
want it no hair down there I literally I
said it out loud for confirmation you
all approved you had your chance to veto
the poll and you didn't it looks like
people don't know what they're voting
for people literally ladies voted to
kill Uber drivers just now like without
realizing they thought they were like
ending abortion okay
it was close no we don't it's fine
listen it was very close it was very it
was about a split decision there on the
hair no hair
okay interesting there it is my man's
working for the Kentucky GOP you know
what I mean listen you had your chance
sometimes
come to the committee meeting do you do
you not want
s to abortion
[Laughter]
um anyway oh this episode is sponsored
by stamps.com thank you we love stamps
who doesn't love the stamps the stamps
stamps are the best we love them okay
whatever teddyfresh.com Black Friday
sale goes through next week so you guys
love a week left but you better get on
it quick because that [ __ ] is selling
out [ __ ] thank you
I love the QVC music yeah
also so let's just get right into it um
LA mayor race yeah uh Karen bass takes
the dub from idiot [ __ ] loser Rick
Caruso who spent a hundred million
dollars of his own money to take this
fat [ __ ] L I'm gonna be honest I
think you and I are like the only two
rich people in Los Angeles that voted
for care
like literally everywhere everywhere I
go like I was looking at the Rick Caruso
uh post about like losing I know so many
[ __ ] that are like underneath
it going oh my God I can't believe you
lost why do they care about Rick Caruso
because he was pumping it so hard he was
going up to like every influencer first
of all he ran the weirdest campaign ever
lost 100 million dollars this is L.A
mayor race by the way the L.A mayor race
not it's not a national which by the way
ironically is like not that powerful of
a position it has a lot of influence
obviously it's this you know the second
largest city I think it sets you up for
bigger things uh yeah like Eric Garcetti
whatever happened to Eric what is he the
Ambassador ambassador to India North
Korea or something he took Ambassador
did India yeah no it didn't set him up
for big things no actually mayoral races
are not setting you up ironically
everyone always thinks like the mayor
the Mayoral race for a big city like
that is a good thing it's a horrible
thing it actually okay
I'm cold
oh baby I can't believe you are a [ __ ]
dude you're a [ __ ]
you just said oh my God my nipples are
showing and then you just showed nip I
didn't say my nips are shot but like I
it's nothing people didn't see me
sitting in in my himbo shirt already
that's crazy yeah it's crazy you just
started [ __ ] rip that off like that
yeah sorry it's hot got a little hot in
here though I'm sorry
um I'm gonna shave my dick tonight for
you
nice
um okay so getting back to the
conversation I I'm like I'm so frazzled
now it's just you're just yeah sorry
mayor of Los Angeles
it's so crazy yeah you're talking about
how the LA mirror okay so the LA mayor
um Rick Caruso went to like every
influencer he possibly could yeah and he
had these like closed door meetings with
influencers it wasn't even like
full-blown fundraising or whatever but
you know he's a real estate developer
he's a billionaire uh he wanted to put
you know he wanted to concentrate
homeless people in a camp
away from Los Angeles
that doesn't sound weird you know yeah
you want to concentrate homeless people
in an area in a niche in a camp there's
a business
I don't know I don't know what was gonna
happen because you can't force people to
like well it's still like a human rights
violation to do that like you can't
force them to stay in the camp so I
don't know how he was planning on doing
that anyway but that was his goal Karen
bass also isn't great she she basically
was also running on like no we're gonna
keep doing sweeps just like Eric
Garcetti was doing
um so nothing is going to change in Los
Angeles it's [ __ ] awful and uh we
just basically averted uh
it becoming worse it was like bad or
really really much worse that was the
choice isn't that wonderful
um yeah yeah well you know what I'm just
happy that like this it's just I'm tired
of these billionaires coming in and
acting like they can do the [ __ ] they
want it's like no [ __ ] sit down
you wasted 100 million dollars now go
back to your mansion in Calabasas or
where the [ __ ] you live and just go away
dude yeah I think I think personally
it's really embarrassing how all these
celebrities fell in mind to support him
um Katy Perry Katy Perry is like the
biggest Rick Caruso simp yeah like she
posted she even went maybe you're a
firework
right you said do you ever feel like a
plastic bag that's not Katy Perry do you
love that Katy Perry yes I got it right
one time holy [ __ ] do you ever feel like
you lost a hundred mil
yeah
um yeah so um but anyway [ __ ] Rick
Caruso whatever uh take this L idiot
loser and um
um yeah uh Katy Perry even went as far
as to take a picture of her at the
uh ballot
filling in Rick Caruso as if we didn't
believe her
yeah if you want to have fun with it go
look at like uh if you look at this [ __ ]
if you follow if you follow any
Instagram models you're gonna see all of
them under Rick Caruso's post it's very
weird like all these Instagram models
are like I'm not he's so many
we hate the homeless Rick you were
supposed to save us yeah I want to turn
homeless people into plastic
there's a way to we can turn their
bodies into oil so heartbreaking
dude y'all really looking for another
billionaire to [ __ ] save you like we
haven't we know now this does not work
this is important this is important for
people to recognize though Beyond
heartbroken I've been [ __ ] sounding
the alarms for a year and a half now
about like the LA crime narrative
running
absolutely rampant and and so many like
liberals that otherwise are like oh my
God I love gay people like BLM you know
in this house we respect BLM unless
they're homeless in which case we should
belt them you know like that like
Liberals are liberals are one light
Breeze away from just straight up
[ __ ] uh you know going Fort Reich on
the on the homeless encampments
you are really upset about this yeah you
know I love this but uh uh FaZe Banks he
actually called me and was like yo you
want to go to a Rick Caruso meeting and
I was like [ __ ] yes blanks like
absolutely you went to a rally it's not
a rally is there like closed door
meetings I was like [ __ ] yeah but it
never actually happened I don't know why
I don't know if he like told the Rick
Caruso team and they were like no I saw
that I saw Banks hanging out with Rick
Caruso yeah but he must have been gutted
poor guy he was just absolutely
I'm sure he doesn't I'm kidding okay
thanks Big don't give a [ __ ] about
anything the guy's mind is blank as of
whoa whoa that's my that's my homie
that's a desert
respect face banks in this house the
only thing inside FaZe bank's head is a
tumbleweed I don't agree with you I'm
face I'm double phased up you see this I
don't agree I don't agree with you no
you know I'm phased up [ __ ] yes dude are
you kidding me
one Tumbleweed tumbling forever
um okay but anyway
um what I'm trying to say is like where
are larger there are larger uh uh points
to draw out of this okay and uh one of
that is that like Liberals are very very
uh quick to just immediately go full
fash when uh they see like a homeless
person they're like oh I saw a homeless
person crime is out of control on the
streets we need to [ __ ] kill people
immediately I'm moving to Texas
every alpha male uh influencer comedian
all these uh manosphere I'm moving to
Texas okay so homeless people are icky
here I want to give some shout outs here
okay
um I want to give a shout out to Hugo
Soto Martinez Council District 13.
Council District members are more
powerful overall as a collective than
the mayor they're like basically uh
they're they're I don't know how to
describe it they're like uh like a Earl
you know what I mean these guys they do
hold a lot of power okay and uh if you
recall the LA Council was like very
corrupt very racist uh and and also
incredibly anti-homeless
um and you know who goes through my soda
Martinez he's uh he's a union guy you
know he's a union organizer uh came from
the hospitality industry and I think
he's gonna do great things you know I I
know him I fundraise for him you go uh
Kenneth in in City controller is another
good one too for CPA uh now Kenneth also
First Filipino uh I think member of of
any like La uh office
uh Kenneth Mejia
uh won the Los Angeles uh City
controller position
the reason why I'm bringing this up
is because
Kenneth ran for a year uh he's he's kind
of a Zoomer he's young he's like around
our age he's very hot
um attractive yeah he's very
attractively can we both got a cute dog
too
what he's got a cute dog yeah
not at all yeah thank you I heard he's
hot so he has uh he basically has a 21
point lead over the prior the incumbent
city council member uh Hanson I like his
dapperness
with the bow tie yeah why am I bringing
this up though this is a city I wonder
if he shaves his dick
okay I I don't know about that but he
was a former organizer for the LA
Tenants Union and he basically had one
of the most outwardly Progressive
campaigns one of the most outwardly
Progressive platforms you could run on
he talked about decriminalizing
homelessness and most importantly
holding the police accountable I've used
some of the I've used some of his info
on my stream for years now almost like
he would always talk about the police
budgets you might have actually even
used some of his numbers on leftovers or
in other places because he was very he
was very public about his disdain for
the Los Angeles Police Department a
little uh context the LA City budget is
like what 60 LAPD or is it even more
yeah something along like billions of
dollars and they're always every year
like no we need more actually that's not
enough
so he would do he would do these like I
mean he ran a he ran a billboard he had
a billboard that basically showed
um
he ran a billboard that showed how large
the police budget was in comparison to
everything else yes yes yes
um if you go to his website like Mejia
for controller.com Budget you can see
that uh the proposed City budgets
and the reason why I'm basically
mentioning all this is because Karen
bass okay which was uh one of these
details for for Joseph Robinette 3.1
billion [ __ ] dollars yeah please
Karen bass uh came from you know uh she
she did a lot of work on the ground like
Inglewood and whatnot and you know she
was a congressperson
but she's an Institutional you know
Democratic Party Machine politician
uh she's feckless she's a feckless
institutionalist she's you know she's
not going to make broad sweeping changed
she ran on also doing sweeps on homeless
people like on homeless encampments so
their their position on homelessness was
like almost identical like her and and
Rick Caruso
Kenneth got at this stage has gotten 10
000 more votes for the [ __ ] City
controller that is interesting in the
goddamn LA mayor it's the same thing we
keep seeing on a national scale is that
progressives do great and when you run
crusty old [ __ ] who are like status quo
Democrats they
do at best barely winning but like
there's no enthusiasm and why are
Democrats so [ __ ] afraid of
putting out progressives yeah she has
he had he has more like 10 000 more
votes than Karen bass right now like
that's insane that means like some
people that refuse to vote for either on
all the ballots that have been counted
some people that vote refuses over
either because I don't think anyone that
voted for Rick Russo voted for Kenneth
was literally voting for Kenneth
ten thousand more people that's that's
very significant considering how openly
Progressive his platform was it it
certainly says a lot about uh you know
running a good campaign and I'll be
watching I'm excited to see what he uh
what he has to report on the LAPD the LA
Police by the way budget is 46 for the
fiscal year 2022 to 2023. yeah that's a
lot of cheddar by the way let's get on
to the drip Justin Trudeau and Joe Biden
showed up
[Music]
the dick really called Asian I don't
know how you say a Sean why do they say
e-s-e-a-n how about we just what is it
supposed to say Asian Association of
Southeast Asian Nations but it's like a
it says Asian like I think it's trying
to be clever with the acronym a little
bit hey Shawn Asian it's a little racist
they're making you say it in like a way
that's like a little racist hey Sean
nobody's making you say it like that
that's why they've got to do that to me
nobody's making it I'm trying to be a
woke King and they're out here spelling
aishan nobody's all right anyway look at
the drip dude Biden is [ __ ] killing
him he's swagged out he swagged out
straight up swag [ __ ] swag dude yes
why he walk like an NPC bro he looks hot
okay let my man let my man breathe like
he's [ __ ] 800 years old bro hello
traveler I used to be like you three
walk cycle yeah yeah awesome yeah he
took an arrow to the knee listen he's
like 800 years old okay he's like wow
it's sleepy time for him he's he doesn't
know where the [ __ ] he is on the planet
he does it am I still a Wisconsin Jack
look alive
why am I wearing this well I got this
silly jacket on mate
why am I wearing this next step Che
Guevara
chase that you so that that in itself is
a is a good story actually they're
attending the the Asian Asian conference
that's how they spell it no you are it
says Okay Sean okay
um these are not actually Mao jackets
this is traditional shirts worn from
Cambodia so yeah respectful King we
loved that yeah
um I mean it's drip regardless it's yeah
drip or die essentially for Joe Biden
um here's some headline that's gave me
uh some hope and actually surprised me
respect for Marriage Act passed the
Senate yesterday 62 to 37 this bill uh
asked to protect uh same wait hold on
same-sex and interracial marriages did
we need that they have confirmation on
the interracial yes oh we did well it's
I think the reason why they did it is
because one Supreme Court conservative
Supreme Court Justices straight up said
you know we could reconsider these uh
these things as well like they signaled
that they would do it two it was also a
politically astute politically smart
move why because you don't want to look
like you're a [ __ ] gigantic racist
you want to look like you're just a
homophobe right
um which is weird that's like the
Republicans are defending it saying
literally that they're like nah you
don't understand it's like because they
put it together like it's an Omnibus
well Rick um let's see here Marco Lil
Marco Rubio said I don't know why we're
doing this build there's no threat to
its status in America and then he goes
on to say I know plenty of gay people in
Florida that are pissed about gas prices
the slam dunk no he's I know lots of gay
people that are worried about gas prices
he's uh that is the best way to try to
counter something like that on the
messaging side the worst way to do it is
what Ben Shapiro has been doing he's
been losing his [ __ ] mind like he's
cut multiple videos with Matt Walsh Ben
who last week was saying like
Republicans need to like still do the
culture War stuff but also like stick to
policies be a little bit more moderate
it's obvious that like you know Trump is
having a a negative impact on the
independent voters in the suburbs right
and then this entire week is like
homosexual should not be able to marry
one another like so that really his
stance I haven't seen it no his stance
is his stance is that you know it's not
natural
uh and that um you know no matter how
much the government like legislates
something it's not going to make it
natural how could something that feels
so good not be natural you mean butt sex
I don't know just being in love Yeah
well oh he's mad about that too he's
like Love Is Love it's not this is not
about love this is about marriage
marriage is supposed to be between a man
a woman and a child he kept saying that
too it's very weird it's like what and
because if you make child marriage legal
illegal that who's gonna marry me I mean
I look like I'm 12. so like how am I
gonna get by a marriage is supposed to
be between a man a woman and a woman and
the woman's tennis instructor
my wife is a doctor
um I hadn't seen Ben going off on that
I'm gonna try to pull a clip of that
so
Mitch McConnell by the way who's in a
interracial marriage
voted no
yeah we love that about him that was
fire he was just here's the clip brought
to you by Hassan's Twitter
he's so brave he's so brave Mr McConnell
no why not just vote Yes
um
is called the protect same-sex and
interracial marriage act yeah no this
originally started off almost like a
meme like a messaging Bill Republicans
and Democrats love doing stuff like this
where they're like it's not going to get
past anyway whatever who cares you know
so they put it out there and then
Congressional Republicans were like no
we're on board with this and enough
Republicans in the Senate said like yeah
no we could vote for this that's fine uh
Mitch McConnell ironic because uh you
know he's had a little bit of internal
conflict in the Republican party so far
for the uh you know for the leadership
position in the Senate Rick Scott wanted
to go after him and like uh try to win
over the Republican Party didn't happen
Rick Scott [ __ ] loser hold this
l-rick anyway
um
I don't know why I'm riding for Mitch
McConnell but he had come out numerous
times before signing no on this bill and
even after this bill and said we need to
be more moderate we need to start doing
bipartisan [ __ ] with the Democratic
Party in the Senate and this is like a
moment of bipartisanship why the [ __ ]
did you vote no on it because I don't
believe in the gays it's such a gimme uh
yeah Ben still flubbed it Ben Shapiro
says even martians would be opposed to
same-sex marriage now how the [ __ ] would
you know that
you could be a visitor from Mars and you
could see that all of human procreation
relies on man woman child oh No Just man
and woman please I like my relationships
without the child you [ __ ]
freak okay let's watch yeah I mean Matt
he has Matt Walsh with him that's why he
had to bring the child in there dude
Matt Walsh is the worst I I think I I
think he's the most disgusting person
alive perhaps Matt Walsh is a fan of
this show I'll have you know play it
that show the leftovers which is a great
show by the way yeah wait what the [ __ ]
yeah somebody found this no he's afraid
he's a fan of our show
shut the [ __ ] up yeah other leftovers
bro oh my God for a second I was like
what we got him ladies and gentlemen we
got him
leftovers which is a great show by the
way thank you Matt Walsh uh thank you
for the endorsement there
is that it is now apparently the law of
the land and societal rule that the only
rationale that you would possibly have
for saying that a marriage is between a
man and a woman is because you're a
Christian or a Jew or a Muslim that's
really the only reason at all that the
only reason we'll allow you to have
these crazy beliefs so long as you can
show that they're crazy
um
a hundred percent that's true I like
come on no atheist is out there
screaming marriage between a man and a
woman it's just not happening yeah like
well it is but but notice how Ben is so
this is a very clever thing that Ben was
doing for abortion too
if you if you listen to Ben he never
talks about why life begins at
conception which has no basis in science
whatsoever it's just a religious
doctrine that he maintains is just the
law of the land just the truth so he
never makes he never finds himself
making the religious argument well he
also can't make the religious argument
because he's Orthodox Jew and there's no
such thing like abortion is quite
literally allowed in his uh
understanding of the religion again I
want to say according to the Torah and
Jewish belief
I don't know if this is what's in
practice but this is what it says in the
Torah
life begins at first breath yeah
so you're a [ __ ] bad Jew [ __ ]
yeah so so but he all he always made
like the rational logical argument which
was that like no it's just it's just
murder it's just murder it's just a baby
right like he never actually examined
the premise of where that comes from
like why life begins at conception he
never brought up religion when he was
making that argument now he's trying to
do the same thing for gay marriage which
is a huge l i mean that is not a good
argument at all because there is no
logical [ __ ] reason to try to keep
marriage between a man and a woman just
like there's no logical reason to you
know deny bodily autonomy to women but
like
I don't know why he's just like going
after even more unpopular things now
right same-sex marriage 71 approval
highest approval it is ever had in
America it's gonna get even higher from
here on out you know what I mean I mean
it's incredible like the freaking
Republican Senate voted for it to pass
this bill that surprised me and God
bless them I think that's great no even
even mitt [ __ ] Romney voted yes on
that [ __ ] yeah well the Mormon the
Mormon Church actually recently patched
their religion once again for those of
you who don't know yes the Mormon Church
uh came out and said you know patch
notes
was uh I I don't believe in it but
you guys do whatever you want that is
what America's all about thank you Mitt
Romney nobody asked you to [ __ ] watch
gay porn just you know what I mean don't
get in our way
um adult incest yeah thank you huh
Prager
yeah um I I don't know if Ben is because
in Israel um abortion has always been
legal and I wonder if Ben is worried
about what's you know in in Israel that
he should be concerned about that right
yeah Israeli babies or being murdered
yeah the biggest genocide against
Israelis is happening in the hospital
bed when women are killing their
childhood that's a good take I wonder
why I wonder why he never talks about
that yeah that's interesting yeah that's
what I'd like to know his opinion on
I'm sure that the reason you believe
that marriage is between a man and a
woman is because you read it in a book
and because you really believe the book
they keep saying sincere religious
belief I don't even know how you measure
a sincere religious belief how are we
gonna like now monitor how often you go
to church or to synagogue whether you
keep kosher or whether you take
communion in order to determine your
sincere I mean the same media that
declares that Nancy Pelosi is a sincere
religious believer who's just for the
mass abortion of The Unborn children
a little clear that you Matt Walsh are
not objectively wait pause it for a
second the irony of that statement is
that he's like you can't tell when
someone is as sincerely held religious
beliefs and then immediately follows
that up by being like but Nancy Pelosi
is fake her her religious beliefs are
not sincere I don't know why did you
just say that what who's even having
who's worried about sincere religious
belief I don't give a [ __ ] I don't think
anybody gives a [ __ ] but Nancy always
like is like I'm a Catholic yeah it's
fine letter yeah parents you're a bigot
right and your religion is a cover for
your bigotry I'm I'm highly annoyed by
the constant derogation of non-religious
arguments into religious arguments and
this is what the left loves to do they
like to say you're pro-life the reason
you're pro-life is because of your your
crazy religion and so maybe we can
respect your crazy religion along that
that is not the argument from error it's
the argument for marriage has literally
nothing to do with religion you could be
shut up visitor from from Mars and and
you could see that all of human
procreation relies on man woman child
this is not particular no no no no no no
no no child that's weird man woman
yeah I don't know why he said I don't
know why he just said a child comes
after yeah not in the bedroom yeah what
the [ __ ] outside after the bedroom Ben I
don't even I don't even let the dogs
watch you know what I mean I'm like get
out yeah
the children stay they have to see this
have you ever had a dog like lick your
lick your nuts or something while you're
having sex no well because because
because
not that you want to but the dog's in
there with you I had and they try to get
all I try to get it a funny story I do
have a funny story where he got into
abruptly because this girl I was seeing
had this like gigantic pit bull and he
had like major separation anxiety and
we're in the room the doors closed this
[ __ ] Behemoth jumped up like was
scratching the door jumped up and
actually opened the door okay like
literally jumped up at the handle yeah
and was able to open the door yeah and
I'm I'm you know I'm in the vinegar
Strokes moment okay I'm like I'm ready
it's just like the last few you know
what's what do you mean vinegar you just
like you're like smelling vinegar like
uh like that
never heard of that and and you know
and I don't even notice and then I feel
something jump up at the bed like a big
presence
and it was the dog yeah and I almost got
defiled I I've never pulled my pants up
faster and left the house like I left
one sock behind you know what I mean one
sock was still on the foot the other one
was like I left out scared that the dog
would kill you I just well I didn't even
think at that moment I was just like
what the [ __ ] I just like pulled
everything up and I booked it I booked
it out of the house interesting I was
like hey have a good day okay
um you know I'm I'm done I did not [ __ ]
my dog well uh good uh did you [ __ ] the
dog no I did not I was I was more scared
that like like what if what if that
[ __ ] thing like chomped at my balls
or something yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah and doesn't let go
that's what pitbulls do no this is about
here let's oh you know I'm a big pitbull
advocate well Olivia was just attacked
by a pitbull legitimately Pitbull sorry
I'm not I'm not bad though I'm not
anti-pitbull that's what I said it was
bad owners this is literally fish my uh
my pitbull that passed away this is a
name damn rest in peace King rest in
power
so maybe I want to hear him say uh
marriage is between a child again and
and respect your crazy religion along
those that is not the argument for
marriage the argument for marriage has
literally nothing to do with religion
you could be an a visitor from from Mars
and and you could see that all of human
procreation relies on man woman child
this is not particularly difficult stuff
my procreation does not include a child
yeah no even the Martian would be like
doctors that's weird bro back up they'd
be like yo I'm from Mars back the [ __ ]
up
what did you just say
the funniest thing is the funniest thing
is like martians that come uh on the
Earth are gonna make this like they're
gonna look at human beings as like
something that's like a separate entity
or an organism that's different than
like the rest of the animals you can't
make the natural argument that like
first of all it's a fallacy regardless
the entire existence of mankind is you
know defying the laws of nature so it's
a fallacy it's like the most common word
used by these Christian objectivists
Judea Christian objectivist
um as I pointed out on my Twitter like
there's animals that are gay as [ __ ]
what do you mean like nature there's
like trans animals gay animals like
there's animal kingdom is crazy man
also who okay so so according to Ben
Shapiro we need to nullify all marriages
where they don't have a child if you got
a vasectomy hypothetically speaking
let's say you got a vasectomy that
marriage is null and void yeah if you if
you've tried out a baby for more than
two years and been on it we need to
nullify that marriage and try again with
somebody else this is what marriage is
about every martial would know that if
you're not [ __ ] a kid who well okay
who's maybe not a kid but hypothetically
hypothetically in the room like a 13
year old a boy for example could
probably impregnate a woman but the
younger the better
yeah yeah what is a woman
I'm still trying to figure out what a
woman is yeah
in favor of traditional marriage into
well if you're a crazy religious
believer maybe we'll let you have that
but you know if you're baking it if
you're a cake baker then we're not sure
about that right I mean like we're not
sure how far this is Let's Talk About
the Cake thing what you're really doing
is you're setting the ground game at
same-sex marriage and traditional
marriage are completely the same thing
and if you object to it the only reason
that we'll even allow you to do this is
because of this crazy thing called
actually he's right though uh-huh I
personally think right that he he's
acting like it's a joke but but it's
actually 100 the truth the only people
that object to uh gay marriage are
religious uh people I don't think you
can find a single atheist yeah I've
never he's gonna be like I don't I
believe that men and women is a holy is
a sacred institution I think you
literally just created a new type of
right wing freak just now like you just
spoke it into the world like ah you're
gonna see like red pilled atheist guy
who's like yeah I think like it's
illogical and scientific to hate gay
marriage well if you're out there I'd
love to hear from you know because oh
don't say oh no all right let's thank
our sponsor real fast we got one sponsor
and they are stamps.com hell yeah it's
the holiday season and Chaos always
comes no matter how much we prepare
you know it's right now seasonal
excitement or dread it's really starting
to settle in especially for small
businesses and here's where we can help
stamps.com is your One-Stop shop for all
your shipping and mailing needs for more
than 20 years stamps.com has been
indispensable for over 1 million
businesses and this is the best part
here one of the best parts You're Gonna
Save so much money with stamps they've
got major discounts on USPS and UPS
shipping rates up to 86 off
the reason they get those fat discounts
is because they bring so much business
you can negotiate down the price and
that's the power of stamps.com
yeah it's a stress the uh stress-free
solution for every small business
um use stamps.com to print posters
wherever you do business all you need is
a computer and a printer and if you need
a package pickup you can easily schedule
it through stamps.com dashboard
rates are constantly changing when stamp
stock comes switch and save features you
can easily compare carriers and rates so
you know you're getting the best deal
every time and if you're running an
online store stamps.com Works seamlessly
with all major shopping carts and
marketplaces
um stamps is awesome I know that we talk
about this but Dan's uh girlfriend Ali
uses stamps and it is sure does freaking
way man to streamline your shipping
thing we've been printing them stamps
lately I hate those lines man I hate
going to the post office I'm always
thinking like how can we streamline this
process from home yeah stamps.com yeah
exactly you identified the problem and
the solution yeah you don't have to
think about it dude you really don't
have to think about it here's how it
works you get a scale they send you a
scale
you weigh the package
right there in your house you uh print
the postage put it on you can drop it in
the envelope or you can even leave it
out on your porch and they're gonna come
pick it up elves yeah elves yeah looks
like a tooth fairy it's kind of a that's
that's just but for your package yeah I
mean my mailman is pretty short but like
there's no reason it did oh there's
your mistaken I thought owls were always
connected I thought else were all right
maybe I'm thinking of
you're also thinking about like Santa's
helper elves like those were short but
like canonically and all you're talking
about like High Elves like wood elves
why they pick up my packages Just Elves
in general like are lanky and tall and
like beautiful I thought like ethereal
elves magical Cinder and elves but um
you know the noldor elves are they're
not as fair and they have uh darker hair
y'all are such nerds bro okay oh my God
I'll put that on me embarrassing yeah so
stamps.com
um is the One Stop Shop it's gonna make
your holiday season so much better this
holiday season trade late nights for
silent nights and get started
withstamps.com today sign up with the
promo code leftovers for a special offer
that includes a four week trial plus
free postage and a free digital scale
there's no long-term commitments or
contracts just go to stamps.com Click
the microphone at the top of the page
and enter the code leftovers yes thank
you thank you to stamps we love you
stamps please consider supporting our
sponsor yes yes
I love when the call to action is like
seasonal
like yeah this holiday season trade late
nights for silent night that's actually
a nice line yeah I quite like that one
good one good one to that so let's see
um who wrote that
we have so much here that I
I'm afraid of missing stuff so I'm just
trying to prioritize but like the Tucker
Carlson interview of Ali London oh my
God yes
yeah maybe we should watch that because
we talked about ollie on this show
actually we almost got him to call in
whatever happened to that Dan you could
have saved him uh or you could have
saved Co I if I it was a long time it
was like two years ago um I remember
what happened with Ali we were trying to
get him on the show yeah he reached out
to us too I guess I mean we don't care I
guess I can just say it right yeah I
don't give a [ __ ] yeah you you decided
you had no interest in talking to him oh
I Kai boshed it yeah you could have
saved him dude that's interesting my
method of conducting the show was a lot
different back then yeah yeah today I I
definitely have his ass on nope no
question about it
sexual fantasy well he's probably he'll
probably see this so if you want to call
in and talk to us so yeah so Ali London
he's this uh guy who famously
trailblazed the trans-racial movement he
yeah wanted to be what was the name of
that BTS guy jimin he wanted to be jimin
actually so bad he changed his race to
Korean and tried to look
sound and act like jimin as much as
possible oh by the way all of these
[ __ ] phonies throw it up oh yeah we
love BTS I love BTS yes
army yes I pledge allegiance to the BTS
flag aren't they invisible aren't they
like don't they have to enlist now or
something in the Army dude me too I'm
the first thing I'm enlisting South
Korean army yeah support them
send me in with them [ __ ] it
um yeah so Ollie London is went from
being transracial to now and also trans
I guess he he became a trans woman I
didn't know he did that he wants to be
Rachel dolezal so bad there's only one
Queen okay you come at the queen you
best not miss [ __ ] that's what
happens that's what happens all right
Rachel Dole is all my queen
oh Trans racial she actually pulled it
off though she did her own her only
friends was popping dude wait what oh
you guys don't know about Rachel yeah
she has the only fans oh custom no she's
she's yo you know what's so funny I
haven't seen this photo she's like the
whitest girl ever yeah and and her
original as you said patch notes yeah
her beta version yeah was straight white
yeah she was she was ride or die if you
guys don't know the story of her she was
pretending to be a black woman most of
her adult life she was even the chairman
of some yeah she was uh she was like a
leader in the NAACP yeah yeah
you know that's so sick wild and then
you know pull up that thing because I
think it in an interview they they get
her right they're like are you black
uh it was like during an interview I I
canceled that out from my memory because
I don't know what you're talking about
because you know she's my queen
so you so she does she does only fans
she has the only fans she does hair
still okay so she does she does a lot of
she does hair for a living oh my God
it's real wait Harry like down there no
she does hair for a living like she does
people's hair only fans and hair yeah so
only fans not paying the the bill
I think only fans is just the side
hustle for her I think her true passion
is is uh hair Dan what are you saying
describe it for the people well it was
just in Google Images so it was all
censored stuff from articles or whatever
uh that's awesome here here just I guess
probably probably still too racy to show
but if you just look at it yeah let me
take a look but you yeah you after oh
[ __ ] get off thank God I just [ __ ] do
that
I opened it on the show screen yeah
there's actually nothing too bad here
yeah but as you you absolutely noted
that yes she she was kind of nice Blazer
and all these following she's kind of
nice with it yeah Ollie's standing on
her shoulders
um yeah anyway yeah so he's now gone now
he's anti-trans so he's come full circle
and he's on Fox News talking to Tucker
about how uh children are being
brainwashed uh by by trans uh propaganda
he's decided he's had enough now he's
transitioning back to being a British
man we thought we would ask him what
that experience was like Ollie London
joins us tonight
and has seen [ __ ] bro bro this is the
most popular news broadcast in the
[ __ ] country dog that's crazy this is
what Joker looks like without makeup bro
America is not a real country America is
not a real country I repeat this is
insanity okay
and and there's there's only two ways
out of this like I feel like this this
like gender sicko narrative that the
Republicans have been running on are
either going to keep annoying the [ __ ]
out of like uh you know Suburban moms
and stuff
or they're all gonna get like super
invested and enough people are gonna be
completely brain melted into being like
yeah we gotta [ __ ] murder these
gender sickos
you know it's just terrifying Ali London
is uh he's flip-flopped so here is bro
there is not like I've said this so many
times I think like it is a diagnosable
mental illness if you are are thinking
about trans people this much trans
people do not think about trans
activities this much okay and again it's
like one percent of the population
[ __ ] ridiculous dude it's like a
trans person can't fart in a [ __ ]
subway station without Tucker Carlson
making it national news it's insane like
and and this person is not even like I
don't even know what to categorize this
[ __ ] uh Behemoth as okay it's not
like a trans person no no he's he's a
troll or at least he's always been like
a like a super uh you know he's always
been like a psycho who just wants
attention I think I think the real
answer is history on a personality
disorder yeah by the way the other the
other thing the other thing is like the
Ontario teacher was another great
example you remember the one with the
Bazooka the big ass it is yeah like
that's not a [ __ ] trans person
they're just like crazy person I agree I
agree but you're just you're just trying
to desperately use the largest platform
you have to be like this is how trans
people are like right look at this and
then most people like I don't [ __ ]
what let me tell you guys uh so here's a
little uh path of Ali London white
influencer Ollie London has 18 surges to
look like BTS star jimin and now
identifies as Korean as you can see
super successful
um look just like
uh this and then he says this is my new
official flag for being a non-binary
person who identifies as Korean actually
I kind of vibe with the logo it's pretty
good this is what this is what I knew
like I mean I knew that this person was
like out of out of his mind right but
when he did the whole like oh this is my
Neo pronoun I was like no okay like this
guy is grifting like this guy is going
and this guy's going full grift he's
history on it I think to be totally
honest um Ali London I've rejected my
trans identity to follow Jesus now I
want to be baptized so so and then and
then finally on Tucker so let's watch
that it's really fascinating
um so why did you decide
to become a Korean woman who told you
that was possible
so obviously I've had a difficult time
with my gender identity struggles I was
never unhappy with how I looked so I
started changing everything Korean woman
and I realized that was a big mistake
and I just want to be a boy but you know
is there anyone that people like me and
young people want to change their agenda
when we have the normalization of this
in our schools in this country dude this
guy is such a [ __ ] piece you know
what the funniest part about this is
like dude bro you're old like it didn't
even happen to you apparently like this
gender [ __ ] yeah that's going on in
schools now three days was not the
reason why you became this uh [ __ ]
weirdo you know no no no no no no no no
how old is he because yeah he's been in
the he's been I didn't even know I
didn't even know he was like
transitioning to being a woman I didn't
even realize that that was a part of
this equation like 32. he kind of fell
off the field stop but it's just so
disgusting how he goes through all this
[ __ ] and then just to throw trans people
under the bus us and like be like
they're they're making kids pissing
Kitty boxes and that's why I became
trans dude you graduated high school
like the same time as me idiot yeah it's
just what happened you just you just did
it on your own yeah I guess children are
taught from a young age from the age of
five in some cases but it's okay to
change their gender it's okay to you
know wear a skirt it's okay for a boy to
use agenda neutral toilets when it puts
girls at risk this is the norm and
schools are teaching about toxic
masculinity they're eroding the alpha
bro he's so British this is the most
here's the thing British people is we
call it Turf Island for a reason like he
went full Brit like he went Brit mode
you can't escape it you know no matter
how hard you try to become Korean you
still come all the way back to being
British baby you know no escaping it bro
yeah trans people in bathrooms you may
be able to change your gender but you
will never change your nationality you
are English and you will always to be
English yeah and but I think
there's in a box [ __ ]
um I think he's trying to get a show
because this is like the perfect no shot
he's the perfect
he might no he's the worship a [ __ ]
floor Freakazoid like Tucker Carlson
will weaponize him for like three
broadcasts until he realizes that his
audience is gonna be like bro stop
showing me this [ __ ] freak yeah maybe
maybe but he's he's found a new audience
and he's found he's found something that
gets him attention I think that is the
major problem with a lot of these like
anti-trans sickos is that like they're
like Matt Walsh like they are so
obsessed Matt lost watches I've never
been more sure of anything in my life
but they're constantly [ __ ] great
show by the way
they're constantly obsessed with like
the genitals of children nobody wants to
hear that man like you're you're going
crazy you're out of your [ __ ] mind
you're like literally always talking
about like children's genitalia and
trying to do penis inspection day at
school like parents at a certain pointer
gonna be like dude calm down I don't
want to [ __ ] hear about this anymore
this is too weird
yeah I think I think we're gonna see all
the making the rounds of conservative
media because this is just way too
useful of a uh of a pond for them well
it's been eroded you know Taco what
happened years ago when kids used to go
to school they used to idolize Superman
and astronauts you stupid [ __ ] idiots
shut the [ __ ] up Ollie no I think I'm
did you have plastic surgery on your
brain you're missing half of it I mean
that came before I think but he no I'm
telling you this is like Milo like he's
two Republicans Republicans like find
that too weird Marvel was good until he
said he [ __ ] up Milo never reached
like prominent mainstream success to
that degree
he was on the path bro I know but then
and then he said I thought yeah he had
one backer he had one big backer who
pulled out when he just started talking
about pedophilia okay and and the thing
is though like if he had more
institutional backing which he was never
going to reach because he was too
[ __ ] oh yeah
in Milo's presentation was definitely
um a little bit better than Ali London's
in the sense that like he was always you
know Ollie is like very clearly crazy
like out of his [ __ ] Milo yo I
disagree Bill Maher had him on and said
he's a young Christopher Hitchens
yeah Bill Maher sucks but I'm saying he
was he was on
he went all the way he was on Joe Rogan
he was on Bill Maher he he was no but
they dropped him way quicker than they
would like someone like the kid where do
you go I know but Candace Owens said
Hitler wanted to make Germany great and
she's still a pretty prominent
conservative broadcaster no it's
presentation is someone's presentation
is good like she can still
um she's the [ __ ] the kid bro my my
test for this is like can you bring Ali
London into the uh living room of like a
Suburban uh White conservative family
you can't you can with Candace Owens
they're racist but they'll be like she's
one of the good ones you know what I
mean but you can't with Milo anopolis
and you can't with uh Ali London they're
too like they're too weird I have
something to say
um I found out his pronouns um all these
pronouns are oi and brov oh my God
yeah that was from the chap that doesn't
shout out to the chatter also or if it's
not oi and bruv it's core and Ian or it
was corn Ian it's not anymore now it's
oi and bro
okay so moving on yeah yeah whatever
[ __ ] him uh Elon Musk don't care let's
move on to we talked about the midterm
uh Herschel oh I want to watch this yeah
so oh we talked about the midterm last
week everything's going pretty good uh
the Dems Are Gonna Keep the the Senate
the Republicans are going to win the
house narrowly they they already did
yeah they officially have won the house
and they already started immediately uh
as of last night we're [ __ ]
investigating Hunter Biden baby let's go
oh really did they go straight into it
yeah are you serious yeah [ __ ] yeah I've
been waiting I was finally we gotta look
deeper into that laptop with his they
better be ready if you swing for the
king yeah you better not miss we're
gonna be so we're gonna see Hunter Biden
dick reveal
dude we already saw him smoking crack
and having sex with prostitutes with a
gun to their head it's like what do you
what else you looking for nobody cares
he's dumb we like that we love Hunter
Hunter forever
I'm hunting for hunt Goodwill Hunter
Goodwill Hunter
yeah so Herschel Walker they're doing a
runoff between Herschel Walker and uh
what's his name
Rafael Warnock yes uh Herschel Walker
got 50 almost 50 of the vote and this
guy I cannot emphasize just what a
horrible pathetic uh candidate this is
that is almost winning in Georgia
you're fired you got 88 of the
Evangelical vote despite his opponent
being a literal preacher and uh well
listen to him he's you know he's
campaigning because there's going to be
another a runoff election so he's
campaigning hard here is um from one of
his recent speeches makes some really
compelling arguments here about vampires
and werewolves
thank you
oh do you ever watch a stupid movie late
at night hoping gonna get better don't
get better but you keep watching it
anyway because the other night the other
night I was watching this movie I was
watching this movie called Fright Night
Freak night or some type of night but it
was about vampires I don't know if you
know vampires and cool people are they
not but I'm gonna tell you something a
werewolf can kill a vampire did you know
that I never knew that I don't want to
be a vampire anymore I want to be a
werewolf but then anyway as I'm watching
this movie and then you tell you how
stupid it is because it's one in the
morning so I'm watching my TV of these
kids watching their TV or vampire kill
on their TV
at that house yeah so they were watching
their TV movies I'm watching my TV
they're watching their TV or they see
the Vampire killer on that TV so they
win right contest to bring this actor
now y'all gotta stay with me bring this
action I'm staying with you Herschel I'm
right there with you every step of the
way
no this actor comes to that home he got
all the right stuff that's right all the
right stuff because you know I gotta
have a state and got to have a thing to
kill them in the heart yeah garlic could
that work yeah I don't know what it does
but it worked gotta have a cross because
it burned I know that worked and then
all of a sudden this is what was so
funny about it and they're walking
through there yes this guy got the holy
water he blessing the house this actor
now he's all fake he's dressed in the
house with his holy water they walked
upstairs yeah as opposed to the real
blessing of the House of holy water
sounds like Senator or not doesn't it
looking all good in this black suit
floated from the ceiling he floated from
the ceiling looking good and cool and
I'm thinking oh they better get out of
that house if somebody float from your
ceiling get out of that house yeah
that's not your house but as he floated
from the ceiling the kid jumped behind
that hero behind that hero the guy
jumped in front of this holy water Threw
It On The Vampire forehead yeah
then he took his hand away he started
laughing
he said that don't work he took
he took it away
the vampire didn't even do anything no
way that's where it is
unless you got faith right
I get it
you've got to have faith my
controversial but
like the vamp parties are you ready for
my hot take
that's good you like it's not that's not
bad the chat is all the chat's pretty on
board with Mr I'll be honest with you
like that that isn't bad because like
look you're by Coastal elitist lib and
so am I we laugh at her she'll walk her
okay we're never gonna vote for her
walker the type of people that are gonna
vote for Herschel Walker are like
listening to that and going you know
nobody followed that he's just like me I
swear I watched that vampire movie I saw
that I saw that and I thought to myself
that's that's a good lesson what's he
going for the vampire vote that by our
cool people vote for me no the werewolf
vote Herschel Walker in the vampires
when Hershel Walker well hold on hold up
what he was pretty he was Pro vampire no
wasn't he saying I didn't know a
werewolf could kill a van like he's no
but he says vampires are cool people in
it and then you put the crosstours face
you didn't do anything the holy water
didn't affect them no he says he's like
no he's like anti-vampire he's anti-vamp
yeah see that's what I thought he will
be losing a big chunk of the Georgia
voters in the Playboy card right that
you wouldn't see I think that people
think Vamp life is a joke dude you don't
understand okay
Georgia Georgia voters are going to go
out to the polls like
baby so you think this plays well with
with his base
um I think that I think Herschel Walker
is a charismatic person when his brain
is not leaking out of his ears and this
is not a moment where he's his brain is
like fully leaking out of his ears it
sounds I mean he's talking about some
crazy [ __ ] but he's like rambling on
he's doing a lot of campaign stops like
this is
um
he's coming across his personally he's
talking about like what TV show he
watches yeah yeah I think I I don't
think I don't think this is as bad as
him being like I got into a shootout
with the FBI which I'm a member of you
know what I mean like or
um you know I almost murdered someone
and then I saw their bumper sticker and
it said uh honk if you love Jesus and I
honked and I decided to not murder this
man like those are moments
where he comes across as like truly
insane right now he's just like he's
just spitting he's just he's just
freestyling I don't think this is as bad
as the way that people present is fun
not that it matters ultimately what
matters is demographics
um
what matters is uh the the Georgia base
of support for uh for
like runoffs usually uh have a higher
participation from higher educated uh
which tends to favor the the Democratic
party uh you know Rafael warnock's
chance Raphael warnock's chances are are
looking good even though Democrats
already controlled the majority so
um bad news
vampire caucus is supreme and that's I I
thought and vampires are pretty cool I
like vampires they're pretty cool it's
like a Joe Biden thing I'll tell you
what mate them vampires are pretty cool
used to hold the water in them face I
mean it doesn't affect them it's like
Faith you sound like that you sound like
King of the Hill he's like Faith man
it's like a Boomhauer you sound like
vampires now you're putting up that damn
cross in my face man that doesn't do a
thing holy water [ __ ] I'll take a sip of
that hold water ain't a thing now come
on man I got floating there in the air
and seven inches
out there Mike
werewolf [ __ ] on my grass and [ __ ]
I got enough taking that [ __ ] on my
grass setting the werewolves out eat the
homeless
anyway
um what else we got uh Nancy Pelosi is
stepping down Nancy in a box uh yeah I'm
so bummed oh man we will miss those
those uh
those policies the twins like Pago big
fan of Nancy breasts thank you Tucker
I'm so bummed I'm so bummed that Nancy
Pelosi is no longer gonna be uh the
Democratic house leader a position she's
maintained for like almost 20 [ __ ]
years Jesus Christ he's just so old it's
like step down I mean she is stepping
down and [ __ ] but I want to ask you so
I heard that everybody knows her husband
is gay now and she's stepping down two
L's for Nancy this past month yeah
that's true man yeah by the way um here
she is walking away and boy will we miss
her she's
She's Walking Away
her hands are the wildest part about
this entire process oh
she was like what
anyway
um hand veins
oh you never saw her hands I wonder what
were you looking at instead Ethan that
you never I just said the attention was
hidden I was looking at the fupa bro
yeah okay look right here
ah bro thinks he's cardi yeah he thinks
he's cardi the van that was a cool man
tell you what man the fangs and all that
and the garlic and all that and the
cross you know floating there
um yeah okay anyway yeah her hands are
wild actually that's [ __ ] with me
yeah Mitch McConnell had the same thing
when you're like seven million years old
and like living off of a steady diet of
adrenochrome
so I have a question for you there was a
um strategy employed by the Democrats
this uh season
that they were boosting and paying for
ads of the most Fringe Mega election
denying candidates and at the time when
I heard about it I was like this is so
[ __ ] crazy that they're actually
going to end up electing these freaks
almost happened but in the case of
the the Democrats actually turned out to
uh handily defeat all of the psychos
that they paid
to prop up the the strategy of course is
that they were trying to help elect the
the crazy Fringe candidates so that
they'd be easier to beat during the
actual election and they seemed to have
called The Pied Piper strategy Hillary
Clinton utilized it when they propped up
uh in in unearth Communications between
the Clinton campaign uh and uh media
figures where they were like keep
covering Trump keep pumping Trump trump
is the guy to be Trump is the easiest
person to defeat they were wrong that is
a very prominent and very famous example
of the Pied Piper strategy failing it's
high risk uh really high risk in my
opinion uh perhaps too high risk because
we did get Donald Trump the secondary
component of the Pied Piper strategy
which I've been incredibly critical of
and this is one of the few issues that
me and Sam Cedar disagree on because he
does see it as an overall uh you know W
he does look at this because the results
on the short term are pretty obvious
it's pretty clear
um
one of the earlier examples of this was
Claire mccaskill uh Claire mccaskill did
this as well
um and the thing is uh it can work in
certain areas and it and it will fail
dimashably at the national level like it
did for Donald Trump however my fear
for and this is actually a really good
example this one guy was way too close
yeah Carrie lake is not even Pied Piper
though she I think like she more so was
uh trumpian candidate but the reason why
she had uh such great results overall
for Arizona
uh was because Katie Hobbs were in a bad
campaign did not run a good campaign and
Carrie Lake was also famous and had a
lot of name recognition from being a
local news broadcast
if you ignore what she's saying she had
a good stage presence and a good manner
of speaking Yeah so what I'll say is
this my fear for the Pied Piper strategy
is that one it has a tendency to fail
sometimes when it is when it does it's
disastrous you know but in the short
term it might look beneficial but in the
long term it's definitely bad overall
why when you look at a person like Doug
mastriano which was another candidate
for the pie like which was another
candidate that was boosted by uh the
Democratic Party
um Doug Marciano election denier
absolute [ __ ] sicko out of his mind
Christian nationalist like total fascist
guy right die hard was that uh was that
January 6th
why do I think that there's a
Troublesome it spells trouble for the
future of America because hundreds of
thousands and in certain instances like
with Kerry lake or with Doug Marciano
millions of people are still voting for
an election denying [ __ ] weirdo so
you're basically approving you're
basically galvanizing the base of
support for some of the more reactionary
forces especially if you have someone
like Donald Trump that's whipping those
forces and can unify everyone okay that
is a an otherwise like uniquely popular
candidate that has proven to be able to
unite the the more independent voter
block
along with the uh Die Hard loyal
hyper-conservative magasicos
you're going to get millions and
millions of votes for election deniers
and and people who just want to like
melt trans people and homeless people
and [ __ ] yeah it's unclear like how much
they affected it though to begin with
but there does seem to be a real lack of
long-term uh consequences uh they're
really just looking at the short term
here but I agree it's just a little
underhanded and it's a little [ __ ]
weird and it seems too risky like you
said but I'm glad it worked out in this
case yeah here's another way to do this
uh instead of [ __ ] pumping out uh
psychotic Republican candidates on the
other side
uh fix her get out the vote mechanism
and make it easier for younger people to
vote make it easier for poor people to
vote or or offer them something that
they could vote for these are these are
really or run progressives that people
actually want to vote for at all yeah
that's that's a good one too
um you know that's yeah that's my take
on it but maybe I'm [ __ ] crazy you
are yeah you are by the way
Rudy Giuliani tweeted this that's crazy
it does have a check mark uh that's him
that's definitely him yeah Nancy Pelosi
and I do not agree on many things but
them thing thinking I'll tell you what
that was Rudy that's that's pretty easy
first time Rooney's been honest on the
main
horny posting anal sex
all right let's talk about
um
let's talk about Trump He's Back Barber
I think I think Trump coming back I
think there's going to be a civil war a
bloodbath in the Republican party and I
think they're gonna get ravaged they're
gonna get absolutely
I think they're gonna be [ __ ] the
whole party's gonna be [ __ ] because
they got all around Trump everyone knew
Trump was a psychotoxic waste of of a
person when he first got nominated they
all [ __ ] hated him before you even
have people like uh Lindsey Graham lady
Graham
Lindsey Graham who was like if Donald
Trump gets elected it will destroy the
Republican party and you know what we'll
deserve it he actually said that then he
he promptly went to sucking his dick as
he uh and so anyway I think he's right
though I think prophetically he's right
I think Donald Trump is going to destroy
the party you already see the tares the
infighting it's [ __ ] phenomenal I
don't fully agree with you okay and
here's why
I think that and I've been saying this
for a while now I think that the
Republican party's problem is not Donald
Trump I think the Republican party's
problem is the Republican Party platform
they've been pushing wedge issues all
the way back since Newt Gingrich when
they realize that like tort reform and
deregulation
uh was and cutting Social Security
spending was not actually a an adequate
way which are those are the real
policies that they care about but that
wasn't the best way to potentially win
national elections
um you can you know maybe win some local
ones right but you can't really win
national elections that way so they've
been pushing on the wedge issues
abortion gun control uh you know family
uh matters like anti-lgbt legislation
and things like that they've been hyper
focusing on those wedges shoes and we
know that as the culture War right
Donald Trump's a victim of his own
success in that regard he was just the
most successful uh uh person to be able
to you know Advance the agenda like
that's that's why people are yelling at
him because he actually gave the people
what they wanted he gave him all the
Supreme Court Justices and then those
Supreme Court Justices went and actually
literally took away the carrot in the
stick because uh I guess uh the the
analogy here is that uh you know the dog
chasing the car finally reached the car
and now the dog doesn't know what the
[ __ ] to do with it you know what I mean
you got the car what he [ __ ] up they
were never supposed to actually get the
car they just want they were supposed to
use the chase as motivation and get
people to vote yeah so now people are
pissed off but that's not Donald Trump's
fault that's the Republican Party
strategy
I think Trump has he's such a polarizing
figure and the whole election denial
stuff he's really spawned and enabled
like Q Anon and the most Fringe
conspiracy theorist people that there is
a rejection of that level of crazy
amongst the electorate and especially
swing voters that I think they looking
at Ron DeSantis and people like him like
okay you know what let's it's not we're
over the Crazy
Santa but Rhonda Santos is Trump how
many times have we talked about Rhonda
that's the perception he's not he's not
uh denying elections he's not um he's
not denying elections yeah however
however but that but but that's not true
either because the Republican party and
I said this when everyone was like
Donald Trump is an election denier he's
uniquely evil I was like no go back and
look at even the likes of Paul Ryan who
got incredible coverage as this like
great you know Statesman who uh who is
objective and and you know unbiased like
you got a [ __ ] GQ uh profile puff
piece made on him like even Paul Ryan
had at times questioned the results of
the California election like this is a
republican strategy in order to justify
voter suppression tools closing polls
State polling stations important black
and brown neighborhoods uh you know
implementing voter ID or you know
purging people from the [ __ ] uh roles
like voter rolls all this stuff hinges
on them lying routinely about American
elections being compromised and voter
fraud being rampant despite all evidence
pointing to the exact opposite so Donald
Trump just communicated that in the way
that Donald Trump does in a very
successful way that actually
appeals to a uh a lot of Americans in a
way that a lot of Americans can
understand it Ron DeSantis did that too
that's why he literally aside from
Shipping immigrants to Martha's Vineyard
right uh which was a a total frequency
remember he did the he did the police
brigades where he went and arrested but
there's a perception that he's less
[ __ ] crazy but I think that's wrong
that's what I'm saying I think Rhonda
Santos my point is Donald Trump and who
he is enacting Donald Trump being
stopped policies but he's not as
charismatic As Trump my point is is that
there's going to be a giant Rift in the
party I really do think so I agree it's
going to be insane and I think the whole
party is going to crumble I think I
think the party's gonna be absolutely
[ __ ] they're gonna be having an
identity crisis for a long time trying
to pick up the pieces of whatever the
[ __ ] it is they've become that's my
prediction
um and I hope it's true either way it's
going to be fire no there will be there
will be a rift that is good it's gonna
be so [ __ ] good
Giuliani actually said and this is the
verify account Helen Keller is a Dusty
fraudulent [ __ ] pushed on us by
globalist media
Helen Keller does the old fraudulent I
guess you I guess you and you and Rudy
agree on something I [ __ ] hate that
Helen Keller man she's a fraud Giuliani
you nasty filthy sloppy disgusting
filthy [ __ ] animal you know what he's
right this really is vile that is but uh
either way it's gonna be a hell of a
it's gonna be a hell of a show yeah oh I
agree with that and I do I do think that
it's great that the Republican party is
obviously imploding I just think that
the real reasons why it's imploding is
not because of trump but because of the
Republican party's methods
um one of the greatest examples of this
while everyone's talking about like
let's be more moderate let's chill out
let's get someone like uh Ron DeSantis
okay who performed well in [ __ ]
Florida okay and Florida is not the rest
of the country let's not make no mistake
um yeah thank God not for at least in
the near future
I wish there was Waffle Houses in
California yeah that would be nice but
my point is that
um Ron doesn't perform well in Florida
the Republican party is making the
mistake the Democrats do all the time
thinking like oh yeah this guy will be
good for the entire nation uh without
assessing what the what the policy or
the what the politics problem was that
is inherent to the Republican party
which is constantly [ __ ] hammering
the culture War [ __ ] Ron DeSantis did
that as well it worked in Florida I
don't think it'll work nationally
um and and I know this because when you
look at a state like Kentucky
Mitch McConnell was talking about let's
be bipartisan let's do moderation Ben
Shapiro is talking about you know we
need to be more moderate to appeal to
The Independents uh and the and the you
know conservative Suburban voters Ben
Shapiro has been screaming about you
know gay marriage for the past week they
literally cannot stop them they can't
help himself it's the only note they
know to hit it's the only note they know
to hit and if they were to even go back
to just pure policy then ultimately you
got a guy like Rick Scott who is just
very open about wanting to cut Social
Security and Medicaid and all these
kinds of benefits and entitlements in a
time when like the country is not uh you
know the country's voter base is not as
wealthy as it once could have been so
those are really unpopular policies
overall
and the Republican party can't run on
those anyway so they have cooked
themselves and they've trapped
themselves in this box and they're
pushing for these uh cultural issues
regardless Mitch McConnell's own
hand-picked attorney general is going to
be running for governor Kentucky
came out one day after the Kentucky
elections uh where the where the people
of Kentucky which is not a blue state by
any means right
said that they want abortion protections
Kentucky voted for this yeah and the
Attorney General came out the next day
and said nope [ __ ] that we're still
taking it to the Supreme Court that's
that is going to piss off people
yeah I think uh God my hair looks like
you know what my hair looks like you
know when a snow cone you put all the
flavors on at the end they just kind of
get all [ __ ] up at the at the bottom
that's what I'm getting
I think it looks good still
um but yeah I agree it's just gonna be a
it's gonna be a a hell of a show man but
Donnie is back regardless he just
announced it it was actually somewhat of
a disaster there was not a lot of
excitement in fact Ivanka and Don Jr
didn't even show up do you find that odd
no I think they're just
they spread out I mean we'll see what
happens I mean we're so far out from the
actual like uh election cycle like
Donald Trump did actually uh pull the
trigger early partially because he's
under a lot of uh you know legal
scrutiny and he wants to turn this into
he wants to weaponize that I think he's
I think also he's not loving the
attention DeSantis is getting and so he
he wants to uh yeah
that's certainly one of the reasons yes
but and and also he's just like devoid
of a platform he's not on Twitter yeah
he's not in front of the media he's not
seen as like a leader in the Republican
party right now A lot of people are
talking [ __ ]
um and he he needs to perform yeah so
what he's you know
what he's going to do now is like every
step of the way whenever there's like
any kind of like doj investigation into
him he's going to turn around and say
look they're still coming after me
they're still coming after me because
they fear me and they don't fear me they
fear you and he's going to do what he
does best take personal Petty Grievances
and and make them uh you know
make the people on the ground feel like
the it's the exact same battles that
they're fighting
uh from Donald Trump's uh announcement
speech
it was pretty boring except for one part
that really got me excited
um here it is and you guys tell me if
something stands out to you here
dealers and human traffickers these are
terrible terrible horrible people who
are responsible for death Carnage and
crime all over our country every drug
dealer during his or her life on average
will kill 500 people that cannot be true
like where the eyes are loud like hell
no 500 people he said his or her though
equal opportunity uh death squads I like
that that's Progressive I appreciate
that so not to mention he did not say
they them though yeah I know
but we're going to be asking everyone
who sells drugs gets caught selling
drugs to receive the death penalty from
there
I I finally laughed out loud when I
heard that that is psychotic it's like
yeah we find you with a bag of mid
you're dying bye-bye yeah I was like
what are you talking about like uh like
a children that I walk around with a
scale and a baggie we're just gonna put
them to death yeah bye-bye by the way
the Crowd Goes Wild
yes I think that's actually one of the
craziest things he said yeah no he's
been saying it he's been he's been
saying it in his uh because look
you gotta you gotta keep putting your
foot on the gas right and the American
criminal justice system is already so
busted like 18 people died on Rikers
Island in New York which was slated to
close right these are people that were
waiting trial in most cases these are
people that were literally innocent
until proven guilty they were waiting
for their trial date and they [ __ ]
died because of horrific conditions
that's New York State okay that's
supposed to be a liberal Safe Haven
right all around the country there are
gruesome conditions in our uh in our
carceral state in our Criminal Justice
System how do you make the American
Criminal Justice System worse it's hard
you gotta look for a new yeah now he's
just going he's amazing one step further
money let's just put it let's put him in
front of a trench let's even save money
on bullets just line them up you know
that's that's basically that's basically
his proposal right it's like [ __ ]
nuts that he actually said this is just
so [ __ ] crazy he wants to put all
drug dealers to the death Center this
this is so nuts there's no [ __ ] way
where do you get this where's he come up
with this stuff I think he sees awaken
the people I think he sees the same
alhamdulillah I think he sees the same
exact [ __ ] that everyone's watching on
TV he sees like California liberals
going crazy
um the the drug situation ties into
homelessness because they all say like
homeless people are are drug addicts
that's why they're homeless uh the drug
situation ties into places like Ohio
where no drugs we're killing drug
dealers now that's well he's tying drugs
not uh he's he's moving away from
systemic solutions to the drug problem
decriminalization and Rehabilitation and
you know putting his foot on the gas
pedal on on further uh accelerating the
the punitive carceral State uh that's
you know he's escalating instead of
escalating if we find you selling drugs
it will make you take all the drugs on
you you have to take it on the spot by
the way that policy you survive you
survive that policy is duterte
yeah that's like we want but he's like a
fascist he's actually like a fashion
Tyrant freak yeah and and also is man
obviously it's unconstitutional would
never actually become law God forbid I
mean I don't see how it could ever be
I mean that is a far cry if there if we
were coming to the point where we're
death penalty for drug dealing then
that's a very different country and I
don't think he's talking about I don't
think he's talking about the Sackler
family
um I don't think he's talking about the
the dude in Alabama is the great people
the dude in Alabama this big and bathtub
Matt no he's talking about like no no no
he's talking about black people and
brown people that's what he's saying
you guys seem to be forgetting though
he's specifically talking about terrible
terrible terrible drug dealers
that's three Terribles yeah they've
killed 500 people they're mass murders
you know what the irony here is that
like Donald Trump literally the first
step act he signed that in the law and
actually
um didn't he personally offer uh a
release of uh a famous uh older lady who
was uh who was like it was her first
ever uh crime but it was a major drug
crime
killer
um anger now he's like now he's saying
like I'm gonna [ __ ] murder I'm gonna
murk drug dealers did you do you think
that Trump got a new bronzer perhaps
he's looking more Brown and less orange
which I think is probably a nice look
for him what do you think
I think it looks like [ __ ]
right right okay fair enough uh yeah but
I think he's lost some weight I don't
like it I think he found some bronzer he
likes a new one maybe at Dwayne Reed he
found he picked out a new bronzer there
congratulations does that make sense
does that make sister sense yeah that's
[ __ ] insane and The Crowd Goes Wild
in fact
Tucker Carlson uh friend and fan to the
show
um
has this to say about Trump wanting to
kill drug dealers
I love there's no Nuance either it's
like if child's selling a dime bag will
be put to death he's killed 500 or verse
but yeah obviously you can't murder drug
dealers it's just not you can't do that
bro
death penalty
they'll be thrown into a volcano
it's like Donald Trump one of the
craziest Parts about this is like he's
not talking about like serial rapists or
whatever which could have like a broader
uh platform of acceptance right he's
talking about people who are literally
selling drugs because they're poor like
drug dealers no drug dealers like yeah
like I can't wait to sell drugs because
you know I want to kill people uh
they're selling drugs because they're
[ __ ] poor and we're not even
addressing that in any meaningful
capacity we've completely moved away
from the underlying structural reasons
for why crime occurs and uh because of
that we will never actually address it
but you know let's go on sorry here's
Tucker who actually is a little bit
excited perhaps by uh Donald Trump's
suggestion that death to all drug
dealers Florida last night Donald Trump
announced that he is running for
president again if you've been following
his rallies that he has done around the
country for the last couple of years
some of it seemed familiar but there
were parts of the speech where he
offered solutions to problems that you
haven't heard before and that nobody
seems to bring that at least in the way
that he spoke about last night for
example he's right he offered a plan to
fix it he said he would wage war on the
Mexican drug cartels right and Institute
the death penalty for people who deal
fentanyl yes yes yes yes yes last night
Donald Trump Yes actually what he said
that's a generous interpretation what he
said is all drug dealers will be put to
death
yeah
yeah no but but notice how uh you know
he's kind of interesting no but Tucker's
right Tucker is right because he said
Mexican drug cartels as though like
they're not those are the only guys
selling drugs those are the only guys
selling fentanyl on the [ __ ] they're
in Mexico bro they're not here the game
you know what I mean no he he's calling
it out he's saying like we're gonna
execute black and brown people yeah
the uh guys that were like trying to
deal with the drug thing it's incredible
that he tried to repackage that he goes
you know there's something novel here
there's something kind of that I've
never heard before he actually wants to
uh kill all drug dealers
practical practical it's actually
duterte policy but he never mentions
duterte and he always mentions China
which I always find to be very
interesting like because I you know I'm
a big Trump Stan you guys know this
already I watch all of his rallies uh I
can name all of his albums right and uh
one of the things that he always
branches like when he and he even
brought it up in that speech which is
like you know I I
I call him King he says don't do it
don't call me King and uh you know he
apparently got that from uh Xi Jinping
he he's even he he always like promotes
it as though it's like a good policy
that China is doing is like executing
drug dealers we need to be more like
Jane
we really appreciate the uh I'm a fan of
being more like China but just
High-Speed Rail you know what I mean
that's that's me
here is the reaction to Trump's
announcement in the conservative
subreddit which has
before now been a Bastion of Maga
and you can already see the rift forming
uh welp here we go not that one but here
I could see him get I can see him not
getting a ton of support and then
getting butt hurt and deciding to screw
over everyone and run third party oh
Mommy that Mommy Mommy that would be
such a dub yeah
um Trump unites the Democrat base like
no other the GOP will get a sound
beating and 24 if Trump is the nominee
yes sir they are right about that I
really wish she didn't do that
he's going to run he's going to turn
into Hillary 2016 isn't he
whoa that's brutal that's [ __ ] brutal
so like the people on the ground his
main base the this these people they
love him but they're turning oh his main
base is not on Reddit okay no but those
dudes are conservative they were [ __ ]
trumps no I know I know but like part of
his base but that's like these guys are
the these guys are the freaks okay like
you and me they're the perverts okay
they're the politics perverts they watch
closely okay and of course politics
perverts like you and I and the people
that are conservative on the other side
of the political Spectrum are hyper
focusing on political media their
political media consumers and the
political media right now is screaming
from the mountaintops that Trump is bad
once Trump establishes and galvanizes
his base of support within the
Republican Party the republic party will
fall in line because they are
conservative will dramatically shift
you're right it was the same way before
he got elected everyone's like Trump
will ruin the party like nobody
remembers this time is that the people
are not with him as much no the people
that are conservative I'm sure if you
look back in like 2015 he probably said
similar things even though like it
looked very different our conservative
look very good I think the bigger
difference is that he's got a bunch of
L's under his belt at this point he lost
an election it's I I've said this on the
show before Republicans one of the only
good qualities is that they don't like
losers when it comes to politics that's
true and Donald Trump I mean he won in
2016 but he's been taking L's ever since
and I don't know candidates it's just
not the same magic yeah his endorsement
didn't do [ __ ] really it was a curse
more than a blessing they all lost and
so that's a good point Dan I think he's
walking along the lump if you will
I don't know we'll see you guys we'll
see and I'm gonna love it I don't know
because I don't think Rhonda like the
only reason why we know who [ __ ]
Rhonda santis is and his name is because
he is National prominence why because he
looks to Donald Trump he takes his he
takes all of Donald Trump's policies all
of Donald Trump's rhetoric and tries to
apply it and that's and then the liberal
media gets after his ass and says like
Rhonda Sanders sucks whatever
that's just the trumpian method he is
the second best Donald Trump we'll see
it's going to be a firework either way
man and he's also not as charismatic As
Trump too no
dude if Ron DeSantis wins the primary
that's a that's a scary state for
America especially if Donald Trump uh
concedes to him which I don't see
happening no if Donald Trump wins the
primary that's still a scary State for
the United States of America but the
Republican party will uh whip uh all of
the support behind him 100 percent
that's interesting you're right about
that
uh Mike Pompeo says we need more
seriousness less noise and leaders who
are looking forward not staring in the
rear view mirror claiming victimhood
wow no that's like former Ally Mike
Pompeo I think like him constantly
a victim card bro yeah but that's
conservative but that's conservative
politics conservative politics literally
revolves around uh perceived victimhood
narratives that that really motivate the
base and
um
this is [ __ ] too by the way Murdoch
tells Trump he will not back fresh White
House Bill no Murdoch was anti-trump
back in 2015. okay so [ __ ] Murdoch
Murdoch was anti-trump back in 2015
people forget
it's okay I know for a fact I know
people I know that Rupert Murdoch turned
on Trump a little bit during covet like
personally I know that Rupert Murdoch
did not like Trump's covet policy he's
like a big coveted guy even though his
entire media institution lies about
covid for a living and makes money off
that he himself personally doesn't like
he's a rich guy you know he's old he's
Rich he's like actually afraid of covet
But ultimately
group of Murdoch is uh going to do
what's best for uh rich people
Milo who we were just talking about a
former darling of the Right Said Trump
supporters want heads on Pikes and the
enemy's Loved Ones Weeping over their
battered Corpses
we are not remotely interested in the
guy we saw last night what do you want
he said he wants to kill all drug
dealers is that enough for you he could
choke and if he doesn't change he will I
don't know what it says but I imagine
lose or something so yeah not extreme
Milo wants more violence he wants more
uh death and hopefully
um
yeah so what's the plethora I'm just
gonna deliver that no like they're
you're seeing a lot of this weird
message coming from the Republican party
because they do not want to address the
elephant in the room
uh in when Mitt Romney was dolled out
and rolled out
the Republican party I remember wanted
to change its narrative strategy the
Republican Party noticed the growth of
the Hispanic base of support
uh in the South and wanted to change
their their communication strategy to be
more open-minded towards immigration
Mitt Romney ran on that policy more than
uh you know prior candidates did right
and he got [ __ ] handily defeated
partially because he was boring out of
touch elitist not popular magic
underwear too Donald Trump won larger
basis of support from uh the Hispanic
and Latino voter blocks while straight
up saying some of the most unhinged [ __ ]
about
uh you know Latino people about
immigration like he ran on an
anti-immigration expressly
anti-immigration campaign saying [ __ ]
you to the prior change in in the party
and that was demonstrably successful
the issue is internal the issue is
internal to the Republican Party Madison
cawthorne uh uh disgraced
uh representative the good news is he
still has allies
[Music]
here's his riveting endorsement
I Want a President Who people are
terrified of who's going to push people
out of the way when he's walking up
because he's the United States of
freaking American he represents every
single one of us yes Donald Trump has my
vote and I hope he has yours too yes yes
yes
huge huge huge endorsement there I want
president that freaking pushes people
out of the lane you see it looks so
[ __ ] insane that's the craziest
lighting I've ever seen in my life such
a bright light and a rosy cheeks and
like I'm freaking I want a freaking
prison that's got to shoulder people on
the way because he's a freaking
President Madison what happened you were
supposed to come on my stream dog you
were supposed to leak the secrets of the
Republicans the Rhinos I'm still waiting
you know I love this guy Howard you got
is there who people are terrified of
what is this obsession with like I want
a president who's gonna freaking kill
people they're gonna be scared I want
their corpses in the street I want to
kill their loved ones I want to [ __ ]
their corpse I want to [ __ ] eat their
children
is it just the lighting or did he die
did he bleach his hair it looks like he
believes he's gonna push people out of
the way when he's walking up because
he's the United States of freaking
American he's a freaking American dork
ass [ __ ] loser he looks like a
scuffed Dolph Lundgren
he's very handsome
Madison come on the show man do it yeah
Max I don't know who the [ __ ] Max
Headroom Max Headroom but he looks just
like him
oh his back bedroom imagine cawthorne he
was like kind of this iconic uh uh
television personality uh back in the
80s it was supposed to be that he was
like a CGI character but it wasn't it
was just a dude and makeup got it yeah
well my fine this is my last thing I've
got a song and then we'll let you go
Mike Lindell
um who's never been wrong
ever yeah about anything a guy with
mental Clarity a vision for the future a
guy who like when I think of a an
incredible political Observer I think of
Mike Lindell I mean he's never been
wrong he sees it not for what at all not
weird totally not gross
and so he said you know what
he's at Trump's announcement he says you
know what Rhonda santis is going to
endorse Trump tomorrow
he says everyone's going to follow mine
and support our boy here's Michael
Lindell who's never been wrong here we
are here
[Music]
I just had a ball with um almost all of
them they asked me about uh Rhonda
Santos running against Donald Trump and
I said after tonight Ron will just
endorse him in the morning
you gotta believe me folks energy money
and everything else so very exciting
here and uh you gotta believe me folks
and by the way stay tuned for all the
packets I'm gonna release on the proof
the election was from yeah I mean he's
right about that and he's right about
Ron DeSantis who definitely already
endorsed Donald Trump
yeah um Mike Lindell
I'm sure Donald Trump hates him he must
make you think he's like a Yoki [ __ ]
loser crackhead he has made fun of him
he was on the record they're not on the
record but like there was uh I remember
reading articles about how like
like he would kind of make fun of him in
the room before he would like so he
would mute the phone uh have it on
speaker be like look at this guy he's
crazy he's out of his mind on the crowd
put down the crack mic yeah cracker yeah
anyway we gotta get Mike back on crack
he was so much nicer back then we loved
him we have a good guy sold pillows like
no one else yeah that crack is what
motivated him though we need more crack
Mike Lindell we don't like sober Mike
Pinda yeah sober Mike he's boring
may Allah awaken the people I've only
seen him the man [ __ ] the man killed a
prostitute and
I helped him with Secret Service buried
the body wait what really
yeah wait you just made that up yeah oh
no Mike Lindell did not kill a
prostitute what the [ __ ] I was like what
I did not that I know of I mean yeah
holy [ __ ] dude okay anyway that's all
I've got um anything uh you want to say
to the people before we go
um no that's great I mean look I'm
looking forward to uh the the internal
Rift that is already happening right in
front of our eyes so good uh within the
Republican party uh will the Democrats
take advantage of that no drama
absolutely not they're [ __ ] pathetic
they suck they literally lost seats they
lost a seat in New York they're losing
seats in California which you know there
was a lot of those were Red Seas
regardless but you know it is uh if the
Democratic party doesn't take advantage
of the situation
um we're just you know they will they
will still end up somehow losing to the
Republican party that's like in a state
of disarray
I mean we're just hoping that the
Republicans are so incompetent and so
destroyed by this battle between
DeSantis and Trump and if Trump loses
the nomination he's going to destroy the
party that's what we're hope we're we're
hoping more for the incompetency and the
toxicity of the Republicans and I think
it's I think they're going to deliver
for us I'm just excited to see these
next two years are going to be fire man
I'm excited I'm glad we're doing the
show because these next two years are
going to be histrionic
oh for sure historical and histrionic I
agree with that all right guys thanks
for watching The Leftovers these are the
two only two patriots left is that right
yeah we're the only two backers of
Donald Trump brother we're Patriot a
nation is in a state of disarray I'm
death to all drug dealers I want to say
I knew this band my cousin there he'd be
dealing all kinds of crap he gave me
that man sold me acid it was just attack
it was just a piece of paper with water
on it yeah I want him dead he sold me
fake acid I want him dead can I get a
bounty I'll give you his name kill him
yeah we're voting for Herschel Walker
too yo if they made in Georgia if they
make drug dealing as a death sentence
you can just get your drug dealer
[ __ ] dead if they if they rip you I
was gonna say I don't support that
policy unless it's exclusively drug
dealers that short you that's it because
there should be a death penalty for
those the next time you go to buy a bag
or something you go hey just so you know
bro yeah if you under if you shorted me
I'm a [ __ ] I'm gonna get you kill on
three 3.4 grams that's that's death
penalty [ __ ]
where are you guys buying your your
drugs like it's legal now yeah we live
in we live in Crimea fornia this is how
we used to do it this is I haven't
bought drugs since weed's been legal
what can I say it's been a while yeah I
stopped I stopped doing the weed after
it got legal too I was doing it for the
thrill thank you by the way Ian for the
uh
the Slick editing there all right guys
thank you for watching
um these have been the last two patriots
on Earth and uh we wish you guys a
beautiful day we'll be back tomorrow on
Friday for after dark
and um there you go be good see you
tomorrow
bye death to all
[Music]
that show the leftovers which is a great
show by the way
[Music]